is there such a thing as gentle radiation? What will happen to my arm if I did radiation? I know you
recommended for bone only. So, technically, from a physics standpoint, the sunshine is gentle
radiation. If you're defining gentle radiation as something that's not going to cause damage to tissue,
then there's no such thing as gentle radiation for treatment of kids. So, if you're talking, you have
to use a high enough rad dose of radiation to kill a cell. So, there's no such thing as gentle
radiation for treatment, fidelity of cancer. You are only allowed to get so much of a rad dose of
radiation. That's where you hear people that did radiation, but the times that now the doctor
said, we can't give you any more radiation. You're passed your rad dose, because there is
different rules in the radiation treatment perspective that you can only get so much radiation.
Because there's just going to be too many other damaging effects of the radiation.
The reason why I am more of a fan of radiation to bone than I am to soft tissue is that
you can get more specific to a spot in the bone. It's harder to get specific to a spot in soft tissue.
And you can see quick results with it. You really think of it. You really think of it if there was
magically no ill effects of the radiation. It's a phenomenal treatment to kill cancer.
It was pinpointed that cancer with this lethal dose and you're destroying a cancer. Well,
the problem is you have to get it goes in a vector and it continues. It bounces around the
road. The road is lead line and it's bouncing around the road but it absorbs it to the lead wall.
It absorbs it to tissue. So your tissue will absorb it. So when they're trying to pinpoint it,
they run these vectoral beams at different angles so that they're all going to converge in one spot
and therefore it's going to be a lethal dose at that spot that all these beams converge and it's
not going to be a lethal dose at the spots that those beams go through your tissues and don't converge.
It's the best that can be done but it's still not perfect even though you don't have a lethal dose
leading. It's not killing all the cells that it's going through. It's still
it's still damaging those cells. So damaged cells can produce cancerous tissue. It's certainly not
unheard of. You're going to have people listening to this call right now that have received
breast cancer treatment whether it be a lumpectomy or a mastectomy. It did radiation just
as exactly how the oncologist prescribed it now. They have these cancerous oils
growing on on side of their chest wall because of the radiation treatment. I've seen this
time and time again. So it may be not like tissue radiation because of that.
Though I do think you have to use wisdom but I do think there's a place for it like
radiating bulb that your person is having excruciating bulb. So I think there's a place for it.